okay hello everyone welcome to another
world language design review
looking at various functions as part of
incremental language development effort
duration
changed I mean we added a second
argument and we added some extra
objects that can be
curated
so to speak
[Music]
yeah that's just the built ref page the
the I wonder why isn't grabbing on from
your Docs
that's because I misspelled it ah
so we added a second argument that is
the units that you would want the
duration specified in and we also added
support for date object as an argument
entity as an object
or entity as an argument and time object
also
and the second argument has a couple
variations
absolutely I mean you can do it with
quantities I suppose why not but I mean
if you say to me will it ignore the two
two seconds Let's ignore the two yes
yeah it'll ignore the two it'll just
extract the unit part
it's a convenience we have in some other
places yeah okay
I think you should make it cleared on
your units count
a quantity with any magnitude for time
units and any magnitude yeah and then
you can see the units of a quantity
um
we have a few examples there I think the
the main one that has a bit of an
asterisk on it is entity just because
okay
I mean we we talked about this before I
think there are cases where it's
uncontroversial yep and that's pretty
much what we've stuck to
okay and there are cases where we just
don't have the the data populated
everywhere but you know for most reasons
we can return unevaluated yep that's
what we do so duration of Battle of
Hastings you get one day duration of
World War II you get
or however long you should get depending
on what country you're in probably
that one's complicated yeah there there
is some Nuance there but in terms of
extracting reasonable properties and
giving a reasonable duration based on
the length we're doing things pretty
intelligently
okay
can I try something
uh if you're in Prototype build you
should be okay
that one's probably going to
um is it a recent prototype
if you do duration of today does it give
back does it work
uh you might need today's build for that
to work okay try
yeah
okay all right okay can you just try it
Carlo are you doing that or do you need
me to
I have a prototype downloaded yep
all right give me a second okay but this
error message is also bad obviously
yeah that has changed
okay
okay well explanation of Jurassic Period
gives five point something to ten to the
seven years
okay
okay that sounds good
all right duration
can be considered I think we're here
done with you okay
thanks
all right spherical distance
so is there a spherical position
not yet
um this is using pairs of angles
and we also admit geoposition as a way
of allowing users to say I'm giving my
position in degrees
that's kind of an abuse isn't it I mean
it's a unit sized Earth that's what
you're saying
yes
this is a function that ignores the size
of the sphere
and that's why there is the second node
saying if you want size just multiply
well yes
the problem was that either we include
radius always or never
because we get dimension
I get it but I mean so the only question
is I don't think it will be very common
for people to have Cartesian coordinates
and want to convert it to a circle
position
what do you mean well they know the it's
like XYZ
in the case of Geo geogrid position
right
an XYZ grid position can be converted to
a lat long geo location
yes
and vice versa
we have to do spherical coordinates to
the type of computation
so again we have two spherical
coordinates and from spherical
coordinates
with the same conventions as here except
for the radius
I'm sorry I I spaced into a second could
you say it again yes I was saying that
we have two spherical coordinates and
from spherical coordinates
and for the high oh
coordinates yeah yes
so okay so that's a that's an answer to
that question but but we have a definite
you know Theta 555i
for like a five dimensional sphere is
well defined is that true or no Phi all
right yes it's it's all piangles and the
last one is a two piangle
okay okay
um
okay this looks nice yeah the function
works is with all types of numbers since
the symbolic case as well
it's careful with um
case of points being too close which is
singular with the standard formulas but
but this will get it correctly then
cool it's threadable
yeah so yep
okay there are comparisons further down
to Geo distance to Astro distance Etc so
seems nice seems good
now we need other spherical functions
what are we planning is this Brad here
by the way
yeah I am here
great
nice function oh thanks yeah this was uh
it's kind of a good way to start
learning to be a developer here because
it didn't have too many thorny issues
some of the stuff that we're working on
now is more difficult
um Jose was showing me uh a bug with Geo
that has to do with the clipping of
polygons on the sphere
so yeah Antarctica
well any it just depends if
if the polygon in the whatever
projection if the polygon for a country
happens to overlap the boundary where
the projection is clipping then you know
all sorts of Havoc can happen
and we really need to be able to take a
and do intersections of spherical
polygons but there currently is no
efficient way to do that
okay so let's just review
yes I was going to summarize saying that
that we are moving into General
spherical geometry and and and that
requires
addressing some some long-standing
problems in Australia with polygons
so we have started there okay
and and what about rendering of stuff on
the sphere
um
Brad do you want to talk about little
pigs and things in that a bit yeah
um one of the issues that we have
with the um especially with the data set
of country polygons is that they have a
ton of vertices in there so it's not
like it's not like doing
transformations of a hexagon or or even
of a hat tile has only 13 sides well 13
is a lot less than like thousands that
you might find for the country polygons
so we also need to like develop and
coarse graining functions
that and maybe even hierarchical course
graining functions that we can use to
you know
speed up the whatever calculations we
have to do with those
um why aren't there already issues with
geo with this stuff
I mean because this this coarsening of
polygons has been a thing ever since we
started doing you know data on maps 20
20 years ago or something
right so
the central way to address this is via
tessellation of the polygons and so we
have now A system that selects polygons
in flat space but not yet in curved
space
and so that's why geo rather than in a
sense Geo has been waiting for that
framework to uh to exist
so what we are doing with blood now is
exploring a method that is used very
much in astrophysics
for analysis of statistics on this
spherical uh sorry um on the on the
celestial sphere
and it's a projection called hilpix it's
a hierarchical equilaria
a projection that has very nice
properties
and so we are exploring the use of that
it's pretty fast
and
but so I mean a typical thing people are
going to want to do I think is
I mean
and by the way what about the sorry in
in the
um you know with stereographic
projections and complex numbers and
things what about the
the unit to sphere and representing a
point on it with a complex number
that seems like a thing we should be
able to do
aren't I confused
no we could have such a representation
um I mean being a complex number rather
than a pair of reels Within
feed very nicely in the Geo framework
but
well no but in this framework we can
have spherical distance between two
complex numbers couldn't we
we could do something like that I mean I
I have to mention here that very
recently we decided that this function
is going to be purely real
to avoid all these conjugates uh ABS Etc
that we get
in in symbolic computations with other
functions
yeah well good
but that's okay if it has complex
numbers explicit complex numbers
it could still do the right thing
couldn't it
well imagine that we have a list of
complexes
I think we're
um
it sounds a little convoluted to me like
you want you want people to plug in
complex numbers to spherical distance
and then get the distance that would be
on the like projecting riemann's figure
or whatever
yeah but but I mean maybe the right
thing to do is a conversion from the
complex number to the sphere which is
you know projection right but I am also
that would be better in my opinion
because also this projection from the
Riemann sphere uh probably has some
scale parameters involved
okay but also also we've got I mean this
is like geogrid position isn't it to get
from maybe I'm confused
to project it's fine it will be another
projection wouldn't there be ambiguity
with the threading over lists exactly
that's what I was going to mention
before and also that that's a trick that
works in in the two sphere while this
function Works in in the atmosphere
right okay okay I retract this but now
okay what's our roadmap for other
spherical functions
go ahead I don't think we have a
collection of definite functions yet
what we know is that we need to address
the major issues of spherical geometry
and also something that we are exploring
is is working with spherical triangles
the traditional formulas yes of solving
triangles and spherical trigonometry Etc
okay
relate to spherical image
well you know how big are the spherical
images going to be are they just going
to keep getting bigger and bigger
I assume they're going to be 4K images
and stuff like that you know I assume
they'll be big they'll be standard
images just wrapped on a sphere
and yeah but what I'm really talking
about is like um Improvement in camera
technology
yeah so what's your point I mean so the
camera technology is just going to keep
giving us bigger and bigger files yeah
to some extent I mean and the computers
will get bigger and faster so I wouldn't
worry about it
um
well I mean one thing that I'm thinking
about right now is that the you know
this sphere hold that hold your phone up
to that picture have you seen this yet
nope
hold you hold your phone up to that
thing and um click the click the
whatever and at least
go to that page
is that a QR code
yeah what do you think it is yes it's a
QR code actually
I'm gonna change it I'm going to change
it it's going to be much better now try
that one
I made a mistake puts a box on my phone
yeah it puts a it should put a um uh
like an AR box
yeah but you can actually just
manipulate the object except now I don't
know how to exit it but that's okay
um
it uh yeah it should have a 3D object
that you can manipulate either in AR on
top of your scene
or as an object at least my phone has
you can select the object and then you
can rotate it in 3D on your phone
I see so it's like fixed in in space so
if I move the phone
well in the default case where it says
they are if you move the phone
anyway so things like this
you know we need a way to make a
spherical image right and there are
spherical image formats that come from
these 360 cameras and things
um
and we should be able to store that
and then in the end I don't even know
what the heck it's going to look like
spherical image processing
yeah well the the heel picks thing is a
data model that is designed specifically
for
the spherical data sets well astronomers
made it for the cosmic microwave
background in particular because they're
getting tons and tons of data
um but you know
it seems like we should definitely
have spherical data models
um
as just as a way of making whatever
functions are built on top of them more
clear about what they're doing
right but what do you mean you mean you
mean functions that have
a scale of field or something
on the sphere is that what you mean well
what what the heel picks really is is a
quad tree
um for 12 you know 12 different regions
that are tiled around like a rhombic
dodecahedron okay
um
the quad tree can zoom into arbitrary
precision
right so if you have to if you have to
um
like say locate some data points on the
sphere
then you automatically have a treat a
searchable tree structure
that you know probably has like log in
complexity in the same way that lookups
and ordered lists okay
but I mean
look the question is
okay we have points on the sphere we
understand how that works we have vector
graphics on the sphere polygons things
like that yeah
which have some complexity because you
know you specify three points and you
don't necessarily know whether you want
which you know there are two polygons
defined by that
I'm not mistaken yeah with the inner
outer thing yes yes
um but but when you
program low level and you're not doing
not imposing conventions on the users
you can as a
adopt your own conventions where the
polygons have circularity and that
resolves the inner outer issue
uh sorry I I got distracted by this
comment on the live stream about can one
get this deployment to work
from any
um yeah I I think you should be able to
convince chat gbt I mean you can't
because this is running in the new
version but I mean you will be able to
convince it to make one of these things
I would assume can take any 3D graphic
and deploy it this way or 2D graphic for
that matter
um
yeah
um but back to back to your comment
though that they're
um it would be not the nice thing about
the heel picks as a data model is we can
take a set of points and turn it into
like a density plot or and then those
density plots may be easier and faster
to work with in an approximation or give
us some basic information okay look the
problem is this we have things like
spatial statistics that deal with
densities from points
but they are non-pherical
right
and
you know we just have a boatload of
functions
and I don't know we don't don't want to
have spherical versions of all those
functions
but the question is how do we
you know how do we deal with that
right many statistics functions already
handled the opposition
but internally they resort to equal area
projections around convenient points and
things like that so there is no native
algorithm that works on the sphere
okay but fine but then so if we
introduce the spherical position
function
analogous to geoposition
then those functions could potentially
eat spherical positions
and then do their usual thing
I guess so
I think that's a better way to do it I
mean because because if we're going to
you know we should treat it like the
geostump there's a certain number of
geofunctions that have Geo in their name
and then other functions just eat
geostuff
I mean
look the case of Geo we have not yet
gotten scalar fields on the on the geoid
right
and scale of fields on a sphere are sort
of very immediate
it's a very obvious thing to want to do
yeah so are you talking about
doing that by vertex coloring or as a
sort of an array plot how would you
imagine that
you mean in terms of
in terms of how you represent it I mean
I can imagine different representations
by color as a density plot I mean
yeah let's say that it's just a color
function on the sphere
yeah but I can also Imagine a vector
field on the sphere where you're going
to want to show you know Vector arrows
at different places on the surface of
the sphere yeah
I can also Imagine I don't know if it's
a good idea making a sort of
mountainscape on spear to represent
density as a um
uh as a height function
um
in what would the data format look like
going into those
functions
that's a good question
in other words if it's a scale of field
that is a function an explicit function
of theta and Phi well it's all good but
if it's a list of points
I mean I assume it will be Theta Phi
value
but even if it's a
even if it's a function of theta and Phi
to actually make the graphics object or
whatever you have to sample it somehow
so how should it be sampled
sorry if it's a function like sine
squared theta cosine Phi or something
sure like a spherical it could be a
spherical harmonic I guess
well I mean
don't we have I mean what we have so far
is we have spherical plot 3D
and so we have you know spherical
harmonic y
you know four comma two comma Theta Phi
are not mistaken
and then we say I think it's comma Theta
comma Phi
really
I guess you have to give limits of
handles no you can't
yeah I chatted a way to make the the
color density pull up there
okay
that's a constant value one right and
then like you can play around with plot
points right like if plot points goes to
five or something what is going to
happen
well the other thing we can do here
by the way I do think that Theta Phi
just comma Theta Phi should work in
circle plot 3D
and just correspond to the whole sphere
mm-hmm
well you might want to add a constant in
there
okay lovely
but so what happens if you take plot
points down to something really small
I mean it becomes yeah I'm sure I'm sure
if I if I just very constant uh the
thing will no longer be a sphere
okay
so what's your point here I mean
well the point is that there is some
there is a data model that is hidden
under this calculation and I even
let's see here let me chat another thing
to you
I can try that one
okay
I think are troubled
yeah I mean this is uh is that is
basically a data model
okay
it
um it's it works it's effective but it
doesn't have the nice properties of some
of these other things we're looking at
right so I mean and the one you're
describing it's like somehow it's uh the
universe says quintessence or something
it's a dodec heater or some such other
thing
I don't know what that looks like but
uh it has a it has rhombuses for faces
where the cube has edges
and the rhombuses join four round of
Vortex and three around the vertex
okay
yeah
Okay cool so then with the heel picks
thing when you set if you set the four
point on the Z axis then you get
basically three cycles of
um rhombuses
North cap South cap and equatorial
and you can you just start subdividing
those faces into quadrants and the
quadrants into quadrants yeah I get it
and you can then the other nice feature
about this heel picks thing is that
um when you do this process you can keep
all the centroids for the facets on
um
on
I guess that'd be ISO latitude rings
that are on there not not the coolers I
mean when astronomers report that the
universe is really a rhombic
dodecahedron I'll be suspicious
yeah I think I think not I think they're
looking at maybe Tauruses but
yeah I understand I'm just saying in
terms of data analysis by the time your
data structure is based on
aromatidahedron it's awfully easy to get
you know dodecahedron okay in any case
um
I think that most of the data has this
thing of well we need to sample it
somehow you know yeah yeah right right
okay but so
what would you actually feed in is it a
list you're feeding in I mean how do you
get
I mean you're you're describing the
question of given a function that gives
given is given Theta Phi and returns a
value you're saying you're describing
implementationally how you will sample
that function
which is all well and good yeah but
there's a different okay so I understand
but I'm not sure that's what we you know
these meetings were mostly dealing with
functional design
um
okay so I'm sorry if I'm I'm getting too
much into the details no I'm it's
interesting I'm interested to hear it I
just I just think it's not what we you
know the basic bottom line is that there
is a function
probably related to spherical plot 3D
but it's probably spherical density plot
isn't it yeah we had talked about that
last time too okay fine
well that's what I was that's kind of
where I was coming up with these other
graphs is
thinking of the how what's the best way
to do it if we know it's going to be a
function on a sphere yeah it's fine
spherical plot 3D doesn't no doesn't
well
no it doesn't no it's got extra degrees
of freedom there doesn't it yeah it
doesn't have to make us feel again
repeating just we should make Theta 5
work I I thought it did
you understand I mean I've never tried
that so you can try it now and see if it
works I I don't know no I just tried it
and it didn't work okay yeah we will
suggest this to Brett
I think it makes sense given that it's
such a frequent casing for it's very
popular 3D
I thought it worked but
it's really weird I thought it used to
work
I don't think this ever worked I've
never seen it
okay well it should work
okay
all right so that's so I think we've got
so then we've got then list spherical
I mean it's a little weird that what the
naming of the thing that just puts
points on sphere
well we'll have that in a different
meeting
and then presumably then we would have
a thing that that plots a projection of
the sphere like this thing here how
would I plot the projected version of
this
well that's where we said we're
um getting some bugs
we can certainly use the the Geo
projection engine here
yeah
in the same way that it's being used in
yes we're talking implementation I'm
talking about the design what function
returns this thing projected
see what I'm saying so I mean the the
things with gender 3D are going to make
3D versions like this and maybe it's
pure
you know spherical plot
or spherical Graphics no spherical
spherical plot
should make the 2D version
or something I I don't know exactly what
it should be
spherical density plot
as opposed to spherical density plot 3D
I mean spherical density plot could make
the 2D version with projection
that's what I'm saying we're a spherical
density plot 3D could make 3D version
which needs no projection
this makes sense
yes
as so these will be the functions that
take functions to represent on the
sphere yeah or the projected map
then the question is what do we return
it's the same situation of I don't know
geodes plot versus Geographics
there are functions that produce
so I understand we're turning Graphics
here aren't we
Graphics well that could be something
that is like the equivalent of
Geographics or the equivalent of
astrographics
something that takes Primitives rather
than functions oh yeah no I I know I
know I know but that's not this case
this case is the plot case then we also
need
you know spherical graphics
and spherical graphics 3D
just like we're going to need
Geographics 3D
[Music]
and these would take Primitives like
you know
SSS triangle
but is that that adequate what is
spherical Graphics versus spherical
graphics 3D
spherical Graphics is a projection
Circle graphics 3D is something like
this
makes sense
I suppose
I think it's the right thing to do I
think that because those are very
different used for very different
purposes
um
okay
I don't know what happens if we take
this let me say
that is very weird and should be
reported look at that thing in the
center
it's like really weird thing
ah there's no surface color
boring
it's just a sphere
okay
but if somebody could could somebody
please report this just show this
picture because I don't think it's doing
the right thing there
the AR deploy
this thing yeah yeah this thing here
that Center picture
with the black and white text
oh I got it okay yeah okay you just take
a picture of the the thing above and the
thing in the near deploy and it's not
um not right yep I got it
okay all right should we go on now I
mean yeah this is what I think we should
be doing here
no
yeah it makes sense it's the same
roadmap we had planned for do an aster
yeah
okay
counts oh did did we actually get
through the approval of spherical
distancing
yes looks great
is there are there any weird options or
anything it didn't look like it just
looked it looked good
no no no I think it was all clear once
we decided to be all real the function
became clear yeah
yeah
okay to make it real by being real
yep
it's the discussion on counts here we're
doing a little bit of house cleaning on
some old ild items and these had been
things that had been approved a long
time ago and not really Revisited and in
looking at them you know
both itai and I are not super on board
with some of the the changes proposed
for counts
um one being you know we said oh we
could give a list of objects to do
counts for but we do have accounts by
function
well we could give a patent uh
well except I I I feel that counts lives
in the I mean we have count which takes
patterns yep and we have counts which is
in the tally sort of you know tally uh
isn't it another this function tallies
things
mm-hmm
um and so uh
uh you know I don't think it's
appropriate for right not you know none
of the related functions right if you
you know take level specs or
um I mean some of them take tests but we
have counts by so I don't see why we
need a second argument
right yeah I kind of I got it I get it
again I kind of agree with you I mean
the only thing I can imagine here
but it wasn't letter counts I see also
from Counts
probably because it didn't exist when
no I think maybe character counts are
supposed to be close enough
maybe character counts is fine because
it's
um wait we have letter accounts and
character accounts what's the difference
between them
oh space is not a character it's not a
letter
okay
that sounds like a distinctly boring
function to me
which one
letter counts
I've used it many times
yeah okay all right these don't have any
extra arguments
well I I don't feel passionately about
having additional Arguments for account
cancer
okay I mean level specs
why is that a good idea
somebody suggested it I don't think
there's certainly neither Nick nor I are
suggesting this is a good idea
those were a couple of orphaned things
have been sitting around that I feel
like we should probably ask but we
didn't want to ask them without fun okay
so we added construct in 11 3. it was
also proposed then that we add fold
construct which basically creates an
operator form or sub-value form
I think it's cool I mean I think it's I
I don't know whether anybody will ever
understand to use it
um
but I think it's an interesting idea
you can't do that with fold can you
[Music]
um
I don't think so without something
fairly elaborate right
uh but it's not true you can do it like
that it's just fold of construct okay
it's not true anybody will ever think of
that
it's because we could have that as an
application example for construct we
certainly can
I would have will ever think of this
um
that's um
nice in
it's just this
so it does with the sequence you know
the fold construct function takes a
sequence rather than fold up construct
that takes a list
oh it's a Ply of fold of construct yeah
it is it is it's just that just apply
both construct
how I'm using
no it's not apply it's the anti-apply
right it's list it's it's this
with a list
it's a little bit more elaborate it's
got to listify the XYZ
right which is construct construct a
fall of construct it's that composed
with less straight
if it's this I'm going to be
it can't possibly do that
no
good
no it can't be there yeah it's composed
with this but has to compose how do you
do that composition
I I can do it with a pure function and
That explicit pure function but is there
a way to do it with functional
constructs
at Star list yeah that's what I would do
maybe a little bit more elaborate
nice
it's good exercise we should put that in
to the I mean we should put it into fold
and construct both the graph pages
yeah we can do this case here
um
do we want fold Constructor is it just
totally silly
I think it's too complicated yeah what
is this supposed to be used for
making these things
I don't think people make arbitrary
depth
you know I don't think it's very common
to make an arbitrary depth one of those
okay
oh well sometimes when I use that form
I'm just like separating inert arguments
from things that will change
and yeah in that case it's definitely
not arbitrary depth
right
okay
um probably shouldn't go over these
today
uh
are we really on course for everything
else for 13-3 for for these um in the
ild area
you have any other things that's pretty
much it for the I mean we talked about
emphasize which is now a squiggled uh an
LCC which is kind of a balance between
ild and LCC
um okay
and I see there's a review for geoastro
and dates do we get to have them
um
there will be little of Astra and what
we are going to review around
compilations there
okay yeah there is going to have some
major stuff is that not ready yet
well in these
in this cycle we have been working quite
a lot on on supporting
various uh
things for Astra like a complete new
loud precision
Mathematica so it's not necessary to to
download tons of yup data and also we
have been preparing for the needs of the
future of a race object
in relation to dates in relation to
quantities yep sort of thing so so this
has been a cycle with a lot of
infrastructure that will be used in
major things in 14.
right okay
okay but I mean in terms of Astro what
was the big thing that we I mean Astro
graphics
managed to get out in reasonable form in
thirteen two is that a true statement or
is there a lot more Astro graphics
well we want to improve things there uh
at the same time that we will be
improving uh Geo because Astra is all
vector
right so so it has the same problems
that Dio has that we were discussing
before
and the other major thing that we were
discussing that we were planning for
this release but it's half done it's
orbits
oh right that was the big thing yes yeah
so there is a full framework now to
compute orbital elements of multiple
things and that's quite powerful but we
don't have the object yet so this is the
this framework is used for this FM radio
system that I was talking about before
so that's why it was needed but um
and how is that related to Geo
trajectory
which is also another thing that's
coming exactly it's it's basically the
same the same thing orbits and and Geo
trajectories I mean all bits are more
complicated
in general right we don't have
relativity in Geo trajectories or
Hoffman transfers and things like that
what are those
transfers in orbits like injecting
um
a push at some point of the earth yes
yes yes yes and then you transfer to a
different orbit yeah yeah right I mean
the main point is that it's in some kind
of uh
it's not inertial motion but it's some
kind of um
in a gravitational field it's it's like
it's in free float
yeah
um
what about I mean does that mean we have
to have geo gravity are we then going to
use the geography stuff to determine the
orbital the actual orbital positions
we could but we that's very expensive
integrating things is very expensive so
what is typically done is to store
orbital Elements which are
a description of the orbit I see this
tle thing two round element type things
exactly things things equivalent to that
so the the object moves very fast in the
orbit but the orbit itself moves slowly
so it's it's better to parameterize the
orbit and then the position of the
object in the orbit
I see but but like around the Moon where
there's a big lump in the Moon that
changes the gravitational field
substantially so it isn't spherical
doesn't that mean I mean things go up
and down and they're orbit around the
Moon by by a lot long way is that
captured by the tle stuff or not
the tle have a very short duration
duration like a few days only so you
have to keep updating
but during those few days they are very
good
and then we have the the NASA data which
is super super precise and they include
models of the crust of the Moon things
like that to this to describe what you
are saying
I see but we cannot integrate in real
time those things that's why they
integrated once they create huge data
files with lots of
coefficients and then we use those very
fast
I see
cool
well I look forward to seeing all that
stuff
um
all right should wrap up here thanks
guys thanks everyone yeah see you soon
bye